what a nightmare things like that are
just roaming around and us assholes we
think what being spiritual hmmm I'm just
gonna get on my board I'm just gonna get
on my board be Monster food no I put my
foot in the back out I'm such a pussy
when it comes to the ocean I was in
Hawaii and we went snorkeling divert the
water and you staring down it was cool
we were by this reef and but all I was
thinking is I just need see one of these
motherfuckers and I'm never getting in
this water again one of those
motherfuckers I can't want to do that
now I couldn't I was too heavy before I
was past the weight limit that you could
go do some diving
I would always tell myself I didn't want
to do it but not one do it yeah you can
tell yourself a lot of things right
mm-hmm
yeah Mitch Hedberg must have a joke
about a writing that uh when he gets
money idea who writes things down or he
if he's lazy not that funny how did you
lose the weight um I really just change
him I got a trainer that was a big part
of it and changed my diet and started
exercising but went from a guy who
didn't exercise at all and ate multiple
Philly cheesesteaks a day took guy who
eats a bunch of boneless skinless
chicken breast and protein shakes and
now I work out like six times a day
Wow yeah just seemed like I was gonna
die if I didn't so what do you do for
working out these days uh you know
weightlifting a lot of um I'll see the
data you know just let back a little
biceps
you know when arm rolls and whatnot just
general weightlifting so but you're you
do it a lot yeah yeah yeah do you um do
you fund has a an effect on your mood on
how you feel
oh absolutely how do you how much better
do you feel and how much attributed to
the working out to losing weight or both
of them together it's a combination
definitely the diet and just feeling
better nutrition wise is very helpful
but you know just doing two shows a
night now you know they used to be a
thing for me I used to be like really
retired after
and now as you know no problem I do a
lot of voiceovers and and other little
things and so you know I'm always
bouncing around from going like doing
shows in the weekend and coming home and
then having to go to voiceover on Monday
morning and taking care of my son and
helping him with his homework and just
being able to do that and not being like
oh I'm just
I gotta go pass out I'm tired you know
that's really the biggest deal being
able to take on more so then I'm able to
make more money so I was carrying my
daughter around on my shoulders the
other day which she likes to get carried
around she's 63 pounds and while she's
on my shoulders after you know 40
minutes or so of that like it's fucking
rough like it starts really hurt and
your neck start getting really tired and
I had to put it down and I was thinking
like how crazy is that there's a lot of
people that just carry that much extra
around with them all the time they're
always carrying around an extra 60
pounds and you don't think it's that
much of a deal until you don't have it
and then you walk with it yeah you know
and you realize like and it's this like
even if it's not that like when a kid
sitting on your neck it's not like the
ideal place to carry all the weight they
actually make a thing there's a company
called the outdoorsman they make a thing
called the Atlas pack it's like a
backpack frame and but at the back of it
is like one of those weightlifting posts
so you could slide an Olympic barbell or
Olympic plate on and two plates you put
as much as 90 pounds on it clamp this
thing down and then it's sitting more on
your hips it's way easier to carry
but even that still it's fun it's
fucking sucks man walking around with
just 45 extra pounds on your back sucks
yeah just getting you know just being
like my mid-thirties and being like oh
man my knees are hurting I didn't I
never played football I never did
anything like that my knees shouldn't be
hurting right and just knowing I think I
had to just change just changed my
mindset about like before when I was
just doing stand-up to do it and didn't
think I was gonna be successful it
didn't matter I was just like I'm just
living for today give me free pizzas
give me whatever and then it was like
once this thing started changing a
little bit I was like oh I'm things are
happening I still don't even really know
what I'm doing
if I give myself a better chance and
take care of my health take care of my
body let me see how far I can push these
gift put these skills you know and it
became more about not wanting to waste
opportunities that's very cool
that's cool I like that so your love of
stand-up made you sort of concentrate
even more on your own body yeah that
crazy yeah like not your love of
yourself not your love of your body like
course like this is you have to go
through the more what you do in your
life you're going through it with your
body but it was your love of stand-up I
mean like god I gotta do something bout
this fucking body yeah that crazy yeah
love of stand-up I love my son and love
of fashion and I didn't you know when
you get to a certain size all your
shirts got dogs on them and you know
anymore yeah right it gets like get into
that triple XL I'm happy whenever
anybody does anything that uh that
benefits their health whether it's uh
for whatever your motivation the end
result is always good it's always good
no matter what motivation is positive or
negative you want to prove somebody
wrong you know or you just want to do
just do better just have a better path
you know so it's so it's so attainable
for so many people so many people could
at least be way healthier at least have
way more energy at least I understand
not that feeling of just being like oh
all day and every time I cheat like
burgers and fries and and and like
milkshakes and shit like that if I
really go off the deep end with my diet
I feel like dog shit I feel terrible
it hits me like oh and then you gotta
realize hey man this is how a lot of
people feel all the time yeah that's a
big deal for me it's the same thing just
going off ate half a burger and and was
feeling so sick and then I was like man
I used to live like this every meal yeah
and my body you know it's just a you
know testament of what your body is
capable to adapt to you know
but once you start going the other way
and started really getting health and
you really in your body becomes more
sensitive to it you really are like oh I
prefer not to cheat you know do you
think still gotta have that balance you
gotta have fun there's nothing wrong
with an ice cream or something like that
every now and again some sort of a
dessert but it's it really it's they
they just think that your body has to be
accustomed to getting what it needs
that's what it is and for too many
people they're running on nutrition
deficit so when your body's just not
getting what it needs for long periods
of time then you develop chronic
inflammation and all sorts of other
problems and this is what we're people
are really suffering from you know you
they're suffering from a nutritional
deficiency that's probably lasted for
years they probably never did you know
some people they just they go 10 15 20
years without even thinking about their
dying there's eating dog shit you're
just eating stuff that doesn't have
enough nutrients and your body just
starts to get weaker there's no way
around it and if you just just turn that
start eating salads eating healthy fish
and and and you know some healthy meat
and just take some vitamins take some
vitamin supplements real simple you know
get yourself some multivitamins get
yourself like a little thing at athletic
greens or something like it get your
fucking health online and once you do
you'd be like oh I should you better
this all I had to do and I'm this person
now yeah mentally so much better much
clearer much happier much happier it's
so hard though because we love mouths
pleasure mmm
you know but to the point where people
poisoning their bodies to get mouths
pleasure yeah and it's just you know
constantly pushed in your face everybody
always knows we talk about all the time
you know in the cheeseburgers fifty
cents salad like five six dollars you
know is you have to make that effort you
have to be able to want to cook at home
and it's not it's not made easy and and
that's what I think we become as a
society less cool and less appreciative
of effort you know yeah but there's also
there's something really annoying about
people that want you eat healthy
yeah that do Oh get off your high horse
get the fuck out of here if you're
sitting there and you're having a burger
and fries and enjoying the shit out of
it and some asshole next to yous got
kale with shaved pecans and talking shit
about your diet while they're pouring
fresh olive oil on top of their shitty
salad come on man leave me alone you
know me alone why enjoy something gross
yeah a taster oh but I think as long as
the the majority of your diet is really
healthy then you can get in those fuck
off days it doesn't matter your body
will bounce back just don't don't put it
in a deficit